so what the [ __ ] god dammit oh my god
scared the bejesus out of me oh [ __ ]
dude uh hi hi guys hello my name is
markiplier and welcome back to
subnautica now I didn't expect to be
starting this off so soon something
decided to pay me a visit my ship is now
extremely damaged I don't know what the
[ __ ] that was you know whole no way I
don't believe that for a second okay but
hi welcome back to subnautica now I've
been looking forward to this episode and
also I have not been looking forward to
this episode and we are incredibly
damaged and I have to go repair that
right now but all that aside we are
either we are either going to face
certain death in the depths oh you oh
you why are you - oh it's mesmerised oh
that's a I don't know what happened
there what's happening whose something
oh my god I don't want to know you know
what I don't want to know oh boy I don't
want to know I don't want to know
anything I don't know what I want to
know it's something here I don't want to
be down here
I don't know to be anywhere okay but
either way so we are fine obviously
obviously you're supposedly fine I don't
know if the thumb Peas are but I'm
assuming the ghosts are back so we can
only assume that they're going to carry
down with us down to the depths of hell
and we're going to be totally fine down
there with them with us so what's
happing said we're going to go down into
the lava zone no matter what like that
is definitely happening but first before
I do that before I do that I have to one
read some names and put up some lockers
and number two have to unfortunately I
think use a console command for the
immediate future because some people are
saying that the ghost Leviathan is in
the game but I
confirmed that it is not but that
doesn't mean that you can't spawn it in
so to do that you need to use a console
command and I didn't think I would be
using one in another episode here but
unfortunately I just want to show it to
you guys and apparently it's big
apparently it's really big now I've
never seen it myself but we're gonna see
it together so I'll be right back once
I'm able to show you that so I put the
lockers over here don't mind if I cut
into the pipes like that I'm sure
they're not very important so we got I
am awesome foxy mark I'm not sure if you
noticed but when you picked up the help
signal from the terminal you actually
picked up the blueprints for the rocket
if you check your inventory when you're
reading Robin L Koons note you have six
new blueprints but when you picked up
the help call from the terminal you had
five more blueprints wonder why hope you
see this message that expands your
knowledge so I'm gonna look into that
right now because I don't believe that
for a second do I can I do i what
doesn't seem like it and I don't know
what the hell's going on out there but I
didn't stop by to visit Jeffery Billy
Sam wise and Marshall so I don't know if
that's true
but even the Slee I don't know if I'd be
able to escape but I won't be able to do
anything unless I cure the kirara virus
that is coursing through my veins and
causing me great problems down here in
the reefs not act then there's this new
Bob who gave a really really nice and
encouraging message he said I am don't
mind markiplier if you cheated all I
want from you is the good work and not
die very much and that is so sweet
that is actually legitimately sweet
because I felt bad about having to ug
code to be able to open the doors on the
aurora but now I feel I feel a little
bit like my soul has a little weight
lifted off of it and then there's a
x-axis def X note X X who said mark
legend has it that the ghost Leviathan
is attracted to a big yellow submarine
and allowed dufus who screams at
everything he sees
you've been warned as whatever asked
about dog wash I don't believe that for
a goddamn second nobody can convince me
otherwise okay let me say let me say
before I do this okay I think the bones
of this dead probably ghost Leviathan
are good enough for spawning in the
ghost Leviathan so I believe oh [ __ ]
hell I holy [ __ ]
hi oh hi oh hi oh hi oh you're nothing I
pissed my pants oh hi oh god stop
nuzzling oh Jesus
oh my god oh my god oh my oh my god oh
well that's spooky
uh-oh I don't like that oh my god it has
a mouth oh well okay
alright so it's not fully implemented
yet but that is freaking terrifying it's
not I mean depending on this I'm not
gonna make any assumptions oh hi oh god
oh don't do that oh don't do that to me
oh [ __ ] dude ha ha ha ha ha oh [ __ ]
I didn't know you can actually hurt me I
didn't know you can I thought you were
like you know not implemented okay he's
gonna ghost into the rocks there
everything is fine oh god he's gonna
come back for a second pass whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
maybe it is attracted to everything that
just screams at it hey you be very alone
oh my god oh my god okay so I miss my
friends better thing and oh my god oh my
god oh so [ __ ] scary oh so goddamn
scary
oh god I'm about to run out of oxygen
okay I don't know if it did any damage
to big box Barry but okay swim to
surface yet 700 meters up [ __ ] is this
whole thing about to explode are you
almost dead no you're fine okay you're
fine
you got barely any damage at all whoa
but it sees you out there oh my god Oh
full full full full soften [ __ ] Eimer
oh my god oh geez
it is oh hey hey hey hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
huh oh man it really wants a piece of me
okay then anyway that is the that's the
ghost Leviathan that's a ghost Leviathan
and yeah it's roll-up and huge I mean
I'm assuming that they're gonna put in
an eating animation later on talking god
dammit stop we're gonna put it stop
they're gonna put an eating animation
later on in the game of course because
it's going to kill you but I've also
heard that this thing exists to prevent
you from going too far out in the ocean
and you can only imagine what's beyond
the reef because we've been in a
relatively safe area in this game rocks
a relatively but I've
or on an episode this planet is flipping
huge huge what enormous monstrosity like
this one here in the bones I'm talking
about not like the ghost but what
flippin huge monstrosity exists out
there beyond the nubile universe
probably bad ones okay but that's not
the main reason we're here oh stop
staring at me
we are gonna go down into that lobs oh
sorry
no no no no no aah I think I died I need
to change out the batteries real bad on
this bad boy but that was cool I think
hope it's okay that I just leave it
there well jeezum flip a dick god damn
it okay so we're fine apparently
everything just blew up and that's fine
whatever
okay am I gonna die or what what's
actually happening here can you tell me
I'd like to know Jesus okay but I'm
about to die I thought it was gonna kill
me if it ever attacked me but it just
left me a little mortally wounded so
that's fine and now comes the slow crawl
of a journey down down down down down
into the tips so I'll see you when I get
there
Oh God so much
hahaha a grave boy huh everybody I'm
sorry I mean to be braver than this but
God it's okay I don't know what that
scream was but I think I remember there
being some random screaming happening
inside my brain when I did near this
tree oh god I just hate it so much
hey so much
hahaha it's okay though
I'm gonna stop being a [ __ ] baby hello
welcome to the world and I can't help
but think that those are eggs and if
those are eggs then well unfucked but
you know if they're not then well
hydration detected but if they're not
eggs then I guess that's okay unless it
turns into some giant carnivorous plant
which I wouldn't be surprised and this
ocean of madness with which I find
myself in boy I need the cure I need the
cure
but that's an option that music an
option you can do that
alright fine whatever I'm fine it's fine
we're fine everything's fine
everything's fine
and it looks about the same gotta admit
looks about the same looks somehow
scarier than the first time doesn't it
I'm not invincible
I could lose people blackberry and
everything that's best safe come on suck
it safe
I could lose big box Barrett literally
any second my keys my sonar - oh that's
something and gurgling that's the music
of the deep baby
I'm gonna play that in my wedding if
you're wondering no I'm not doing okay
hi I am less than okay oh boy I am so
not okay I am the everything but the
okay but I'm gonna be fine and yes if
you're wondering yes I'm a little this
baby I know this I'm aware of this back
I am perfectly aware of my [ __ ] nature
it's just I can't fathom the idea of
being down here for the real season does
it tell my gasps anyway now that I've
done all that and I properly said that's
a warper warping in right there and then
okay does it see me probably okay but
nothing it can do when I'm in here so
[ __ ] on you and no [ __ ] on me I
absolutely hate going down this trench
cuz it's it's dead it's just a
passageway for death it leads you
nowhere it only goes to the place where
you should not go and hahahahahahaha
those aliens for thinking that it was a
good idea to build their special base
down here I don't care if the CM /
actually did live down here I don't
keep flying hahahahaha it is dumb
and they are dumb and I hate them just
wanted to glare that to the world
[Music]
sorry don't suck on my button this place
is a madhouse and it makes no God I
don't know what the [ __ ] that was oh god
no oh no oh you're scary now oh you were
moderately scary before and now you're
terrifying oh where are you I don't see
him I don't see him I don't like that I
don't see him I don't like that I don't
see him oh I don't know where he is yeah
oh hi okay alright okay you do stay do
whatever you got to do to make yourself
feel better about yourself man I'm not
gonna judge you just I know that the
entrance down into the depths is around
this castle I just got to remember
exactly where and I think oh just so
long as I don't honk on my horn I think
I'll be okay I just got to find where
the drop-off is is it over here looks
like it might be I think this is it oh
hi [ __ ] off with you dammit don't drain
my power I'm gonna wait until I can
little deeper the deal with that bull
said that's a tight squeeze right there
I don't man did I come this way before I
can't remember maybe I did cuz I
remember trying to squeeze big bucks
Barry through here and I don't think you
worked out too well for me alright Barry
suck suck it in ah
hi hello Oh all I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna get get that wool plaid that guy
just explode webbing my back I just
explode you're gonna [ __ ] get down
there on build one base
I'm gonna build a pocket I'm gonna build
a [ __ ] base that's all I'm gonna do I
know that I know the castles right there
I know that research laboratory whatever
the [ __ ] alien [ __ ] it is I know
that but what I said to have to do a
personal goal for me and me alone oh I
can no you don't what's to build a
goddamn bag down here and if it's the
last goddamn thing I do which I have a
funny feeling it will be the last thing
I do I'm gonna build it right in that
bosom nook mmm I would build it by the
castle but I don't want to go by I
didn't do anything
ah okay I think we're fine
big we're all right oh my god there's so
many more purrs why are there so many
warping [ __ ] whoa what is that oh
that's that's the kyanite I think okay
but I think I think he thong I think uh
sungki sungki lunk then I can built a
base right in here by this kind I
that'll be good to look out upon I
always prioritize good view whenever I
build my stupid face wherever the [ __ ] I
decided to plant it I'm gonna do what I
came to do because that's all I wanted
to do we're building goddamn beige and I
only need to do that except I need some
gourds to be able to get into it because
they need to be able to build a hand
edge and I don't know if I have enough
for that odd Oh shed ah I need glass do
I have pre-made glass somewhere in here
I don't know if I do yes I do
oh I have everything okay so I have that
that good this could be bad a Hispanic
is that just [ __ ] bad idea the gut in
bad idea is a [ __ ] its worst idea
I've ever had
here we go gonna do it anyway oh right
here this is a good nook
oh hi Ray's oh that's great view right
there oh it burns good down here the
[ __ ] I forgot the warper was going to be
down here go all you're such a piece of
[ __ ] you're such a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
you [ __ ] Tommy forgot this Oh still to
fill just [ __ ] fill the thing well
just [ __ ] brildor [ __ ] do it
okay power busy oh I did it
oh I get it it doesn't have any power
huh I need like a thermal generator for
it ah bring any magnetite I don't know I
didn't bring me lewb oh look oh my god
Wow oh [ __ ] I didn't bring any Lube I
know there's no oxygen in here I'm just
getting a breather before I go out there
again me I'm getting a breather oh my
god what's in this thing what kind of
resources can I expect down here Diamond
great gonna help me that lube can i lube
up a diamond lube up with diamonds all
over me Wow it burns real good down here
call a vixen [ __ ] all of you okay [ __ ]
hit it
I built the base I forgot everything I
don't care
oh [ __ ] me everything about that was
awful so we have a base which means it's
not it's not a real base cousin of power
but you know what I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna split hairs here I've got
something with a hatch and that's all
that I really wanted so I was gonna Park
this guy right here where you [ __ ]
stop being [ __ ] down great dick
holes and I can end this episode so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I know that I'm currently being drained
of power and everything is bad but we're
alive when we're down here so in the
next episode I'm going in that castle
and I want to feel I feel I'm a need to
find a cure for the kirara virus and
then get out of here hopefully maybe I
don't know we'll see either way thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know how i'm doing the comments below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]